Let's discuss the answer to our disks and tape
quiz. Tape can only efficiently support sequential axises. We
are reading a large file from start to end,
which is a sequential axis so it's okay to
use tape. However, the disk will not do too
bad on that either. If, however, we want to
read just the first and last byte of a
large file for tape we pretty much have to fast
forward through the entire file on tape. So tape
is not going to do too well, whereas on
disk we will seek to where the first and
then where the last byte is and just read it.
So disk will still work reasonably well here because
the disk is a so-called random access medium meaning
we give it an address and it kind of goes
there. With a tape, it takes a lot longer to
get to any single position because we need to really go past all the other
positions. And finally, a cat would much rather play with a reel of tape
than with a hard drive and there are thousands of YouTube videos that prove
this point. Cats like stringy things much
more than disky things, especially if the disky
things are enclosed in a metal, rectangular box.